on eli malk island in palau  there is a lake like no other  the saltwater lake was once connected to  the ocean but as the island changed it  was closed off  now in isolation it is filled with a  jellyfish species found nowhere else  the golden jellyfish  these cryptic creatures spend their days  migrating across the lake from one side  to the other following the path of the  sun which feeds the fast-growing algae  that this jellyfish species feeds on  and with no predators to keep them in  check the jellyfish swarm and fill the  lake like a cloudy dream  it's safe for humans to swim in because  though these jellyfish do have stingers  they are too small to be felt by humans  gliding through this place feels  otherworldly